this was the precise moment the
earthquake struck the province of la Zhu
for some residents all they could do was
pray this drone footage shows the extent
of the devastation building after
building Street after Street flattened
by the sheer force of the quake
survivors rushed into the streets for
safety and began frantically searching
through the rubble for their neighbors
and friends local search and rescue
teams set to work immediately and more
than 400 more are on their way to this
region which is remote and sparsely
populated some 340 miles east of the
capital Ankara according to the first
damage assessments it was seen that four
buildings in a Lazar city centre and one
in my dangasm five buildings and total
collapsed and there are several other
heavily damaged structures our teams are
rapidly doing further damage assessment
the teams worked tirelessly to free
people this rescuer is on the phone
talking to a woman buried in the rubble
urging her not to fall asleep there
painstaking work did bring some success
this elderly resident had been trapped
for 17 hours inside what was left of her
home the rescuers got her out there were
more than 200 aftershocks and tremors
were felt as far away as neighboring
Syria Lebanon and Iran
turkey is a country that is all too
familiar with earthquakes and their
aftermath but nothing could have
prepared the people of this province for
this and the brady sky news